ladies and gentlemen it's not yet
Christmas Thanksgiving is uh in a week
very excited for this and uh I do have a
Christmas present for all of you this is
from the post millennial Republican wins
Lowden County Commonwealth Attorney race
against Soros funded incumbent after
Infamous gender neutral School bathroom
rape scandal now that headline is a
mouthful holy C crap L county is across
street from us
um technically it's River yeah it's
across the river from us I say across
street but you know like it's down the
street you know it's down I mean
technically just it's right over the
hill so it's right there but uh so we
know we actually know a lot of people
who are who are involved with with
what's going on and it's a very mixed
left and right County but seeing this is
actually tremendous it's not the first
time we've seen Soros Das get get you
know basically fired and uh it's just
it's all around good news news I think
we look at stuff like this we take a
look at the Marvel's failing we take a
look at Bud Light failing we take a look
at all these things y'all we are winning
the Marvel's collapse hilarious I love
that this movie failed we are winning
the culture War people are waking up to
this I had the honor and privilege of
meeting the mother of one of the
students at the Lowden County High
School that was protesting males in the
girls bathroom and so we we had a good
conversation about it and and I was
excited to meet this this person uh her
family has been pushing back and
speaking up and I'm like this is exactly
what we need now we can see Lowden
County maybe Paving the way for pushing
the stuff out what's happening is you've
got these Urban woke people from DC
moving Westward into the more rural
areas and trying to bring their chaos
with them but the people are starting to
resist and push it all back so as we see
all these crazy videos look at this we
got a bunch of these stories here's one
a group of brazen thieves loot Amazon
delivery truck as helpless delivery
driver looks on you've all seen this
they're just ransacking and I don't know
where this is where what the location is
I don't know if they say but the point
is we have we have a bunch of examples
of this here's one firefighters attacked
by mob after responding to deadly car
crash crime is out of control and I
don't know if it's that you know a lot
of people play these stats games so
they're like crime's actually on the way
down but that doesn't take into
consideration what type of crime they're
referring to and could it be that the
reason crime is down is because people
are too scared to go outside or because
they made it legal like in San Francisco
can rob 800 bucks and it's not that's
that's exactly it so in San Francisco
where they're like we're actually seeing
crime on the decline or people just stop
reporting it because they know it's not
going to be ex yep yeah I think
ultimately there is um I like these
stories about people winning and doing
something because it's so discouraging
when you're when you're in San Francisco
and your target has nothing out because
people keep shoplifting I think it's one
of the doors that opens up well why
don't I just take something you know
what I mean and we like to see the
representation of a community saying no
these are our values and you assim to
them or you don't come here that was
part of one of the things I like about
Ronda santis is he stood up and was like
if there are looters they will be shot
you will be do not loot they will issue
shooting on command to anyone trying to
loot and it was like right away after a
disaster what was it a flood or
something a hurricane I think and no
looting this is the most important
aspect of this bibage is notorious in
lden County that's the the the attorney
for having her office stick convictions
for disorderly conduct on Scott Smith
the dad who was arrested for confronting
a school board in a June 2021 meeting
after his daughter was raped in a high
school in a female restroom by a
biological male in a skirt so let me
just say this guy his daughter is raped
and he shows up the school and he's
Furious they end up arresting him and
this lady has him criminally charged and
now she is
fired feeling
good I would like to interview the new
who is it it's a lawyer the attorney
Commonwealth Attorney yeah Bob Anderson
cool P long berson how long is Bob's
current term I don't know well that's a
good move Bob what are you going to do
different do you think that this is the
kind of thing though that and I'm this
is a little bit cynical of me where
people will get excited about this one
race and then they'll forget that they
have to go out and be active and do it
in their communities they get complacent
yeah well the point is when you know
there's two factions on a field when one
side starts breaking and faltering you
don't say Okay pack it in guys you say
charge mhm and now now it is time to as
the the woke lunatics Retreat from the
the the hilltop of culture abandoning
movie franchises abandoning the stories
that we know and love we storm in and
plant our flag and replace what they
have tried to destroy this is a
legitimate route cultural route
sometimes when the enemy breaks you want
to let them flee because you don't want
to run into a potential trap but this is
not a potential trap this is legitimate
C change right cuz hean seen the Patriot
with Mel Gibson good movie at the end of
the fight when the Cor is like is that
btia making the center and then they're
like they start running away and then
once they go over the hill that's the
Continental Army waiting to trap them
and then unloads on the British you know
Hannibal did it to the Romans they call
it the hammer and Anvil tactic where you
you feain a retreat and then they charge
it and that's your Anvil and then you
come around and flank them from behind
as your Hammer well I think this is if
nothing else proof that focusing on the
cultural issues they actually can change
policy and they actually have political
consequences cuz I don't know about you
folks but I often see especially
establishment conservatives Republicans
saying this isn't matter like this is
just too divisive we don't want to get
stuck in the weeds with this well
actually these are winning issues we see
that like parents go figure don't want
their kids to have to worry about sexual
assault in the locker room right they
care about that can you imagine yeah
that'll get people out to the polls and
especially like we see how motivated
especially Suburban moms are when it
comes to the issue of like what's
happening in school so I think if next
year if Republicans are worried about
the Suburban mom vote we actually need
to keep hitting this issue we need to go
harder on it and not back away I
actually feel like one of the ways they
could do that is by pushing like there
are a lot of states that have these laws
they'll get marketed or they'll get
written about as their um they're
anti-gender affirming and whatever else
but really if you look at it a lot of
times they are people voting against or
judges overturning rules that say you
can't tell parents about what's going on
with their kids in school and I think
even Progressive parents would want to
know if their children are going by
different programs and it starts to be
like this unifying issue like if some if
a child makes a choice in school like
that any parent would want to know you
can't decide arbitrarily who is
dangerous and who is not and who whose
kids are secret about this and you know
you know what I mean like there are ways
to continue to push this issue Lon
county is so unique because they had
that specific case but there are other
parents who would get behind I need to
know what's going on with my kids
especially you know what I think is
going to convince a lot of suburban
women to vote for the likes of Donald
Trump or at least someone more right
leaning is in the event that they have
uh male children explaining to them the
late 2010's history of the false
accusations mattress girl all of these
stories in the me tooo movement and
uh when you when you see this degree of
wokeness right now I think what's
worrying for mothers and fathers who
have daughters is this story about what
happens to this guy but what's what's as
worrying to a parent who has a male
child right the destruction of your
son's life because woke people can lie
about him aism of racism bigotry assault
or otherwise and there will be no there
will be no d process there will be no
innocent till proven guilty they will
destroy this person's life these are the
things we need to
stop mhm due process is
legit innoc it seems so basic to it
until proven guilty well I I I
definitely support you process but
there's a there's this also interesting
tension in a way between due process and
freedom of speech I I don't know if you
guys are familiar with Tommy Robinson
but one of the many legal issues that
he's had in the UK was reporting on uh I
think it was like a grooming gang
forgive me in the comments if I get this
wrong but reporting on a grooming gang
trial and the UK had it that there was a
moratorium in the Press because the
official reason was that they wanted due
process they didn't want these people's
names slandered if they were found
innocent uh people who are critical of
it say actually it's to basically hide
the fact that mass migration has led to
an increase in sexual assaults but what
do you guys think about kind of that
issue are we allowed to talk does that
does due process after a certain point
mean that we need to clamp down on
freedom of the press if it means
publishing these allegations that are
unfounded like Weil T to deal with
defamation and slal and these things the
uh defamation liable slander the problem
is times V Sullivan and uh uh in many
ways there's pros and there's cons to
what's called anti-s slap strategic
lawsuits against public participation
basically anyone can say whatever they
want about anyone else so long as
they're all famous and it's impossible
to win a defamation case impossible
unless it falls into what's called
defamation per se where you what you've
said is so shocking and egregious that
damages aren't needed and the defamation
in of itself warrant just you know
Pursuit like I guess the the issue would
be if I claimed Ian kicked a
dog well I don't know you know did I
know it was false is the question in
times be Sullivan and if Ian tried to
assume me claiming that it'd get thrown
out what if you claimed that I was
running a puppy mill and like
slaughtering animals and like not paying
my taxes it'd be like I that's that's
actually I I don't I don't even think
that would qualify feel like if if you
said I was a rapist then that would be
definition per se or that you had a
contagious disease but killing dogs
isn't enough nope probably not
contagious disease is one is there like
aist of criminal criminal activity yes
there's a list it's criminal activity
contagious disease and something so
morally shocking and reprehensible or
whatever like calling someone a pedo is
defamation per se it's crazy I tried to
do the killing the dogs but it's just
not reprehensible enough I guess in this
Society dark yeah well because there are
like Peta kills dogs right it's true yes
they do right and so that's not
considered to be so morally outrageous
that it would be shocking to people to
claim because it's something that
happens there are kill shelters so if
you if you said that Ian was an evil
person who was running a puppy mill that
kills dogs they'd say okay well is that
an opinion statement about a puppy mill
we don't we don't know if this warrants
the you know a level of going to law
going to court over it yeah I think one
of the questions with freedom of the
press is you
know it is accurate to say this person
was accused of this person is standing
trial for this and I understand the
sensitivity of the crimes and it's
people are evil they're and I think this
is what we get from an untrustworthy
press right the fact that you would
present it as like it's a done deal no
matter what this is definitely they're
not presenting any other sides they have
decided there is a narrative and they're
going to follow it through even if they
might throw the word in allegedly a
couple times it's not on recording Nancy
Pelosi's husband Paul accused of getting
into a fight with a male prostitute over
aug drug deal gone wrong and of course
people are going to be like okay well
hold on we know that story that's a big
leap I didn't say it was true and I
didn't say I said it I said he was
accused of it that's a fact statement so
if I report that Paul Pelosi was accused
of getting into a fight with a gay
prostitute then that is a factual fact
statement that is a that is a true
statement he was accused of that by a
whole bunch of people on the internet
doesn't mean it's true I never said it
was true I said he was accused of it
that's a fact and and what's really
tricky with journalists is that they
really only need one person to make that
accusation to be able to write that
headline but realistically it should be
someone in the legal system making a a a
legitimate like an official accusation
which would be Char they activ attorney
generals everywhere who will Levy all
kinds of stuff against you I mean one of
the I'm allowed to accuse Joe Biden of
of taking bribes and I think everyone's
going to agree like yeah he probably did
there's no official govern government
determination so far uh members of the
Republican Party have presented evidence
where that they say asserts this but
it's not been like adjudicated I think
we're still allowed to come out and say
that he is a corrupt mfer who is taking
breads when I look at the word accuse
the definitions they all all the
definitions are to charge with a
shortcoming to charge formally to make a
charge of wrong so if you're not
charging them literally that means you
don't have the legal Authority it's not
technically an accusation I mean mean if
someone go It also says to claim that
someone has done something wrong it can
get a little vague the thing is if I
accuse someone of doing something or if
someone is like charges are brought
against someone theoretically if you're
being ethical you present evidence that
might contradict the point that seems
obvious like if the government says you
know you burned down a building I would
potentially say there are other people
and I would get a statement from you if
you're trying to present information
honestly you're supposed to represent
multiple points of views and
possibilities but that's not really how
it works anymore but it doesn't matter I
mean the definition of accuse is to
claim someone has done something wrong
yeah that's it I guess maybe there could
be an official accusation like a capital
A and that's like when it's a legitimate
accusation from like someone with
authority as opposed to all this
nonsense being slung on the issue is
people are evil the issue is as a
culture we used to have Scruples and
people were like I can't lie in the
newspaper like I feel so bad I'd be
scared like what how could I I could
couldn't get away with that now
everyone's just like I don't care what
happens to you I'm going to do whatever
I want yeah and and in our defamation
cases the victim has to prove malice
that that person acted with the
intention of destroying your reputation
which if you were to be like hey New
York Times you printed something false
about me and they could be like whoops
we didn't know SL we didn't do it SL we
don't care then you can't prove what
extremely difficult you go to court and
you say they defamed me and they'll file
a motion to dismiss under anti-s slap
legislation or times whatever and the
judge has to then agree discovering is
warranted so you have to provide some
evidence they may have like you this is
the crazy thing in order to actually sue
you actual Mal standard in times be Sol
is that the person doing the the LI liel
or slander knew what they were saying
was false which means if someone in the
Press lies or here's my favorite if
someone tweets a thing and it was a joke
a news organization can take that run it
as fact and then say Oh but we thought
it was
real how how do you prove that they knew
that it was
like that's a paper trail that will
almost never ex internal Communications
where they're like well gee I know this
is not true but run it anyway which
exactly never exist almost yep but civil
Tor not criminal yeah so I guess you get
what you get but you know I guess going
back to the main story we got to
Jiu-Jitsu this because false accusations
can bring down Nations if like you like
the Soviet Union would go around
accusing people accusing people accusing
people take them away without a without
a trial or any kind of process reminds
me of America today and it's kind of
annoying because techic it is you're not
allowed to like make a false police
report or anything like that but when it
comes to like all of these like me too
cases or even just the run-of-the-mill a
sexual assault allegation where that
results in a charge where the man is
found innocent or not guilty you would
think that if if there's a person coming
saying that this person like assaulted
me and the man is then then found not
guilty then that should in all of those
cases uh lead to some sort of
Investigation into a false police report
but that almost never happens mhm so
some people suggest that the accuser
serves the sentence that the accused
would have served if they find out that
it was a false accusation I think I mean
I definitely think that there should be
some sort of legal punishment for trying
to ruin someone's life vindictively and
using weaponizing the legal system I
think it should be worse so if
somebody's accused uh like if a guy
commits sexual assault and the and and
the charge is going to be like 10 years
or something then if it's a false
accusation it should be 15 the reason
being uh it was it's one thing for
someone to commit a crime and then have
the government the law enforcement and
the and the court system seek to uh
bring some kind of justice and stop this
person as an offender all of that is a
legitimate practice if the person is
falsely accusing someone two crimes are
being committed one against law
enforcement and the government and one
against the individual who's falsely
accused and so we we seek deterrence we
don't want people to try and use law
enforcement as a weapon against people
through false accusations so that's an
entirely separate crime so they should
serve the sentence of the person of what
would have been for the person they
accused and they should get an
additional charge over the manipulating
and falsifying government you know blah
blah blah blah blah the only prominent
example I can think of of someone
getting their just deserts for trying to
weaponize the legal system is Jesse Smet
what happened barely I mean but he at
least there was a trial thing he ended
up like you know it was a nothing Burger
but still there was at least I when was
the last time you remember someone being
charged with B like lying and leading
police he's still to this day is
maintaining it really happened he he did
an interview with uh was it Charlemagne
I think it was and he was like this what
they said and he was like really like
yeah he's like okay yeah but what else
is he gonna do honestly he's got to go
down with that chip because if if he
admitted it was wrong it's almost worse
for him if he admitted right away he'd
be back by now if right when it went
down he said look we were trying to
bring awareness and we were trying to
you know make people so performance art
piece no he he could have said me and my
friends deed to Stage this because we
felt like other stories of other victims
weren't getting any national attention
and only a celebrity could bring to
light the Inus that were happening I
regret what we did I'm sorry I deceived
everybody and I accept the punishment
yeah and then like he's going to jail or
whatever his charges are I guess that's
what he's really scared if he doesn't
want to be a felon
but we are years past this now and
people would be like oh okay and
seriously his his PR team should have
said own it and claim the issue is like
here's what I if I was a PR guy for Smet
I'd immed mediately do a Google search
for some kind of racist hate crime and
then I would have Justice M be like when
I saw this story and that no one cared I
knew the only way to get the attention
of the press was for a high-profile
celebrity to do it so that's why I
decided to Stage this event and I regret
it or or you could say like I stage it
to bring attention to this case now that
oh yeah now that everyone's talking
about what you should tell talking
exactly I'm coming forward I'm going
ahead and getting in front of it I want
you all to know now this didn't happen
to me but it did happen to this person
you
crisis team it would have been way more
based if he came out and said like right
away like yes I am jce mullet I have
staged this hate crime why every year
over 800 false hate crimes are reported
and people are lying every single day
then then everyone on the right would
have been like oh wow based he's really
uh checkmated us here I don't know what
to do with that chess right I mean one
of the complaints that that Chicago had
was that he wasted resources right that
would still follow him but maybe he
would just make a nice donation to cover
the cost of his you know false ations
there is a way to spin this I think part
of it is that he liked being you know
celebrated as his victim and I think
that kind of attention is very hard to
give up especially is I don't think
he'll really act again at this point
yeah I wonder I wonder where he is now
especially with the Israel Palestine
stuff because like there are a lot so
there are a lot of celebrities that
hitch their wagons to the woke left and
now they're regretting it could you
imagine being Justice mlet and
destroying your entire career over this
attempt at like anti-trump nonsense only
to find out that you're on the wrong
side of whatever this is like he's in in
the entertainment industry a lot of the
people who are running it are going to
be more pro-israel and then all the
leftists who would have supported him in
the in in if his hate crime worked we
going to be anti-is prop Palestine so
it's like good luck buddy at least for
Ethan Klein he can get up and leave the
room Ryan long did a great skit about
that the actor who's not knowing whether
to post Pro Palestine or pro Israel it's
incredible he always had a you know I
said it before I'll say it again it must
be a horrible way to live to be on the
left yeah oh my gosh I almost fell into
it man in La I was an actor until I was
like 27 and it was just shredding my
soul and then when I got into when
YouTube appeared I was like you can I
can actually speak my mind and and I can
make a career out of it the modern
version of the left right it's it's
really simple for people like me and
many others who are like quote unquote
disaffected liberals or post- liberal or
whatever where it's just like we
maintain our positions and we don't care
about what the left wants to do and so
we get excised we get kicked out and
it's like whatever I don't care screw
you guys but I have to imagine the
people like Ethan Klein who decided I'm
just going to agree with whatever
they're saying that dude must be
stressed out for the past month and a
half since the Hamas thing happened and
everybody on his show is just screaming
in his face and calling him a Zionist
Pig he's probably thinking like it's the
end the right will not have him he's
he's a shill he's sold out you know and
the left hates his guts because he's
he's like pro Israel and it's not just
that he was trying to Hitch his wagon to
the left he chose Hassan perer thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net